aha welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this is gonna be my joker movie review a
new beginning for DC films and for the
character itself I'll talk about where
he fits into the pantheon of Joker's
talking about Heath Ledger all the way
back to the classic versions of the
character and where the movie fits in
with a grander design for what Warner
Brothers is doing with their DC films
we're doing a giveaway for movie tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite Joker
moment on the video so the Joker movie
is all about the character Arthur Fleck
a relatively normal person suffering
from some mental and physical conditions
whose life slowly starts to unravel
after he's attacked by a group of kids
on the street he slowly descends through
the movie as darker and darker feelings
come out of him he doesn't get the help
that he needs until he becomes the
character that you know from the comics
as the Joker previously when I heard
that they were doing a Joker origin
story movie like this I was very
skeptical because in the comics the
Joker is famous for never having a
definitive origin story most people view
Batman The Killing Joke the closest
thing you could give to an origin story
to a character like that but part of the
magic of him as a villain and he is
probably DC's biggest comic book villain
is that he's very vague about his past
and that makes him more mysterious and
even scarier and I feel like Christopher
Nolan really understood that when he did
Heath Ledger's version of the Joker the
way he wrote that character each time he
introduces himself to another group of
people to terrorize them he tells a very
different version of his origin story
you want to know how I got these scars
Joaquin Phoenix's character Arthur Fleck
in this world of Gotham in the movie is
very different from Nolan's versions
though so you can only loosely compare
them Heath Ledger obviously probably one
of the most iconic versions of the Joker
ever his performance was amazing
but I feel like Joaquin Phoenix's
version of the Joker and his performance
stands right up there with eath Ledger's
so even if you don't like the Joker
movie quite as much as you like say The
Dark Knight
I feel like Joaquin Phoenix will be
nominated for an Oscar for his
performance the movie itself is
fantastic but you kind of have to know
what you're getting when you go into it
and obviously Heath Ledger Dark Knight
very different type of movie than the
Joker movie The Dark Knight trilogy is
more of a big action film The Joker
is more of a deep character study with
some action in it isn't completely
actionless but it doesn't feel anything
like Batman movies that you've seen
before and that's another one of the
biggest differences is that every time
you've seen a version of the Joker
before they've had a Batman there to
sort of balance out his morality so you
have all these terrible things that the
Joker might be doing like Heath Ledger
going around town blowing everything up
but you have Christian Bale's Batman to
step in and say this is why what you're
doing is wrong no matter what's happened
to you no matter what your ideology is
he provides you with a very concrete
perspective on what's bad and what's
good whereas one of the more unsettling
aspects of the Joker movie is that it
doesn't have any of that
it just has bad to worse because this
Arthur Fleck character you're kind of
meant to sympathize with them and
there's a lot of talk around the movie
people giving hot takes about how that's
a bad thing cannot wait for all those
hot takes to go away but one of the more
difficult things that the movie asks of
us the viewers is what our role is and
his sort of descent into madness in his
origin story as the Joker how much are
we as society responsible for creating
people like this what role do we play in
it you really don't get that from any of
Christopher Nolan's or any of the
previous versions of the Batman this
town needs an enema
you even talk about Jack Nicholson's
character most of the other previous
iterations of the Joker are fairly
conscious of what they're doing at all
times they know what they're doing is
wrong they're out for revenge
whereas the picture they paint with
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker character is
that he's just seeking to get help for
all of his problems in not finding it
from any of the people around him or the
systems within Gotham City so a big part
of the commentary of the film is the way
that society treats the mentally ill his
laugh was great two very distinct from
the other iconic versions of the Joker's
lap it's the first thing you think about
when you think about the Joker his lap
though is part of who he is it's almost
like it physically hurts him to laugh so
hard he starts coughing sometimes mid
lap as if he can't stop lapping most of
the other versions of the Joker laugh
because they want to freak you out
it's more of an automatic response with
his character everyone's been talking
about all the comparisons to Travis
Bickle a taxi driver in Scorsese's King
of Comedy there are some criticisms that
the movie is almost too much of a
blueprint of a Scorsese film there is so
much Travis Bickle in Joaquin Phoenix's
performance in his character in his
origin even some of the shots in the
film
mirrors of taxi drivers scenes like when
he's playing with the gun when he's
slowly sort of working on his Joker
makeup I don't necessarily think that
that's a bad thing but if you're not a
big fan of Scorsese or if you haven't
seen those films you won't quite get the
references so it might not be quite as
meaningful but a lot of people come away
from the movie thinking that this is
basically just taxi driver if it had
been done as a comic-book movie those
are all fantastic films so if you're
gonna borrow from something borrow from
the best the music is fantastic the
cinematography is amazing like I said
deep character study you spend most of
the movie following around Joaquin
Phoenix's character as he's slowly
pushed to violence at every turn as
things start to unravel for him most of
the other criticisms against the film
have to do with the way it portrays
violence there's been a lot of hot takes
like I said and I think it's okay to ask
questions like that but if you've ever
seen any kind of movie and if you
understand that this movie is about the
Joker
I really don't think that it's an issue
I think that a lot of the people that
are criticizing the film for its
violence just don't know who the Joker
is or it's been too long since the Dark
Knight came out and they've completely
forgot who the Joker character is they
don't read comics comparing to other
rated-r movies like Deadpool this movie
is less violent than the Deadpool movie
the difference is is that this movie is
just so much more serious in the way it
treats all these moments so you're just
hitting the thais by Joaquin Phoenix's
performance there's been a lot of talk
about his behind-the-scenes antics on
set it's all part of him just being this
totally amazing totally weird person
that comes up with some of the most
fantastic performances you've seen
seriously some of his best movies are
some of his weirdest characters there
was a deleted scene they posted recently
of his character slowly coming to the
Joker identity as he's writing a letter
to Murray gold the character this played
by Robert De Niro Travis Bickle himself
so there was no mistake that he cast
Robert De Niro in this movie that is
inspired by a lot of Robert De Niro's
earlier films interesting that you say
that because Todd sent me some out an
outtake reel and we cut it down a bit
but well let's take a look at that and
tell us what was happening here
sorry it's not big girls I did yo
senior after dancer fashion I thought
how was that solo in reality he's not
that crazy all the time but that's just
him in the moment I was very happy to
see that Robert De Niro did not phone
his performance in because at this point
in his career he's got so much money and
so many accolades that he could just do
whatever he wants he could completely
phone in everything he does from now on
but his character is a bit of a spin on
his previous king of comedy movie he
plays a talk-show host like Johnny
Carson and a show that Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker character idolizes in watches just
like during Batman The Killing Joke the
character is an aspiring comedian so
Robert De Niro's talk show is something
that he idolizes and feels like he could
achieve some of the recognition that
he's been wanting so badly from everyone
talking about some of the other more
important characters frances conroy
plays his mother she's integral to his
origin story and what drives him to
eventually become the Joker the way she
comes off in the trailers is totally
creepy and totally weird is exactly the
way she is during the film and that's
exactly the way the film needs her to be
so her performance was amazing
za z beets was also great as the woman
that he has a brief relationship with or
tries to have a brief relationship with
the movie does play some really
interesting mind games with her
character in the joker character because
you're taking his perspective so you're
seeing the world through his eyes and
because of his condition sometimes
you're getting false narrations so
you'll see things one way earlier in the
film and then later the truth will be
revealed that things did not actually
play out that way then of course there's
Brett Cohen who's playing Thomas Wayne I
think early on when I first saw that he
was cast the way they talked about the
character made it sound like he was
actually going to be one of the villains
of the film which is a very interesting
twist on the Thomas Wayne character
someone who you've seen in so many
different iterations of the Batman
origin story as a very loving caring
father who cared about the Gotham
community only seen as this great
charitable person who did everything he
could to give money to the people that
needed it in the city Brett Cullen's
version of the character comes off as
much more imperialistic it's a very
different take on the character but
remember what I said The Joker's mind
false narration sometimes you're not
always seeing things correctly and
throughout the film The Joker keeps
getting all this new information about
his backs
that he assumes is correct information
which isn't always necessarily the case
there's a lot of people that tell him
things that later turn out to be false
so this is nice parallel between them
unraveling the story as his mind is
slowly unraveling as he's being pushed
to violence
I thought the set design was great they
made it look really gritty and grimy
like you would expect Gotham City to be
it looks like a slightly more realistic
version of Tim Burton's Gotham from his
original Batman film talking about the
end of the film without getting too
spoilery I feel like they nailed the
ending in a very clear origin for the
character it's a very complete loop
where they could do sequels if they want
to but Joaquin Phoenix isn't known for
doing sequels and Todd Phillips makes it
sound like they don't have a sequel
planned but right now the movie is on
track to break Venom's record for
all-time highest earning October release
so if it winds up doing gangbusters I
feel like they'll try to do everything
they can to get Joaquin Phoenix to come
back but when you think about the
timeline of the film and how this might
crossover with other Batman related
films the way todd phillips has been
talking about this is a DC black label
is this sort of bubble outside the
regular DC universe where they can tell
rated r DC stories hard-core stories
that wouldn't necessarily mix with the
tone of what the other films are doing
even the slightly more serious version
of the Batman that Matt Reeves is
working on I feel like it's not a
spoiler to say that Bruce Wayne does
appear during this film the age
difference between them is so
significant that it would take a lot of
bending over backwards to get the two of
those characters in a film in the future
you would have to have a very serious
time jump to like I said though the
movie is fantastic even though there's
so many hot takes don't listen to that
go see the movie just enjoy it for
yourself and once you do have a chance
to see it let me know what you think of
it in the comments below
overall I give the film a B+ a - it's
not perfect but it is amazing and
definitely will be nominated for a lot
of awards I will do Easter Egg videos
for it this weekend more specific videos
about the ending possible sequel jumping
off points so if you have any big
questions about the movie that you want
me to dress during those just let me
know in the comments below I'll name a
new giveaway winner when I post that
next to Joker video everybody click here
for the brand new flash season 6 crisis
on Infinite Earths trailer and click
here to rewatch that new birds-of-prey
trailer video and easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everybody put on a
happy
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you